celebrating the premiere of six
underground with Ryan Reynolds and Corey
Hawkins in Brazil only on et that's in
unison teamwork guys nailed it mic drop
spy robot
feel good chatter hello Brazil right
crazy right this view is pretty sick
wait you're gonna say pretty amazing is
amazing first time for me in Brazil yeah
yeah yes my first time is sweet so on
the bet in comparison to y'all been here
a few times going out Mahalo is stunning
it's incredible now you guys actually
didn't shoot here but what kind of
cuisines culture experiences are you
hoping to take in while you're in town I
just want to get a second to last night
a little very much in a school night
it's my first it's my first press junket
so welcome to show me the ropes
now you created a bit of a fan frenzy
here in south polyester day Ryan I mean
they basically fans had you looking like
a real-life stunt Europe oh yeah there's
the cordons collapsed and you know I was
a little it was great I think it looked
worse than it was and all I was worried
about with the people that were put but
you could tell as they were falling like
oh they're gonna be fine and I was like
oh but that leg is gonna go so I jumped
up on that on the same but it was yeah
everyone was fine did you had the
reflexes of a cat it was awesome ah yeah
I mean you know my only job that Blake
said as I was leaving was just come home
in one piece so I that was Leigh Leigh
jobs oh my god
yeah exactly anything could happen how
would you describe a Michael Bay film
yeah I don't know that you can it's pure
chaos you know on set nobody knows what
they're doing Michael does but no one
else has any idea you know he just sort
of has governed by kind of a childlike
whimsy but in a good way like he sort of
sheets whatever he sort of whatever they
may here yeah just you can't ask
questions I don't know if you'll get the
answer no boy you're not gonna get much
of an answer at all to be honest we're
all in a support group together now
afterwards yeah sweetie seriously it's
pretty crazy you know yeah this
friendship is forged in pure fire you
know yeah I mean it it was hard but it
but it was also like the challenge of it
cuz you know people's like I'll sign up
for Michael Bay film yeah you actually
don't know but you get on set and people
like I can't get ready for the babe and
be like yeah that's what it is yeah and
that's a real thing but it's interesting
like I look at you know a lot of it kind
of like it's never compares to war but
like you're off and you're in this like
sort of camp to get we're all kind of
out there making trying to make this
movie it's complete mayhem it's chaos
left right and center but like it really
galvanizes people like this cast is
probably the tightest cast I've ever
worked with everyone's looking out for
each other that's that
you know everyone's making sure taken
care of each other III I was I'm really
grateful for that part like and you feel
it on the screen you can tell these this
this family was the screen robbery for
sure now when you sign that dotted line
to say yes I'm signing up for a Michael
Bay film you know he's got protagonists
like Dwayne Johnson Mark Wahlberg do you
mean that leave like hit the gym pump
that iron and eat some raw eggs start
you know getting in that building the
rock as your point of comparison for a
physical fitness no thanks you know the
case is still going through puberty no
no so I would say my Michael was like
you know you really just got it you know
you gotta get in shape you got it I was
like I was like I'm not gonna do you
know and then uh like we went through he
put us through a month and a half like
my characters more on the smartphone
really Ryan he says this is all so
effing dangerous yeah I feel like it
apply to about any scene in the yeah
where some days on set though just rough
when it comes to the action sequences I
mean anytime you're doing a car chase in
Florence at those speeds you know where
are these these tiny streets that you
have an inch on either side and you're
going 100 miles an hour and it's an Alfa
Romeo this lime-green Alfa Romeo was you
know your hearts in your throat for a
lot of that stuff you know and then
there's yeah there's a like that line
wasn't a scripted line it was just a it
just felt like this was also mortars
going off and people falling in though
in the river and or that lake yeah so I
mean that lines just coming out I think
I'm actually looking in Bay's like like
and what I love about Bay - is that like
it's like safety first when it comes to
him like what explosions are happening
that guys wearing a full-body helmet
like he actually found a way to make a
full body
he had cut he isn't a cocoon of safety
hope and shrapnel doesn't good to our
hearts yeah like it's so is it safe to
say after some of those rough mayhem
mayhem days it was time to throw back a
few gems maybe we had some Chin's yeah
we definitely had a few yeah I don't
know if that's your dream but it was
mine I couldn't do it yeah I'm sure
little aviation gin and I got to say I
saw your post recently on in station 2
you ever heard of that
eh engine it might have been the
southern accent carried away sometimes
[Music]